schauen wir nach berlin auch dort wurde
heute gegen die korona maßnahmen
demonstriert und zwar mit einem
schweigemarsch mit dabei und bei mir im
studio jetzt kann es rahmig hannes du
hast heute diesen marsch sozusagen
begleitet was ist da passiert wer war da
da waren ungefähr 1000 menschen aus dem
bürgerlichen spektrum würde ich sagen
viele familien die auch mit kindern und
fahrrädern auf die straße gegangen sind
weit weniger als erwartet angemeldet
waren ungefähr 5000 gekommen sind etwa
1000 knapp 1000 sagt die polizei
eigentlich einen demonstrationszug der
impfgegner auch der gru der gegner der
korona maßnahmen die schweigende viele
mit masten und großen abständen heute
durch den prenzlauer berg eigentlich
richtung tiergarten laufen wollten die
route ist dann verkürzt worden
wahrscheinlich aufgrund der geringen
teilnehmerzahl auch die sollten am
alexanderplatz enden ich habe da am rand
auch gestanden hat mit einer teilen der
inneren vorne in der ersten reihe auch
gesprochen vielleicht hätten wir uns das
kurz mal an wir müssen das jetzt hier
weg gehen weil sich dann gerade den mars
weg gegangen bist du dann zum glück
nicht das ist jetzt eine demo die war
relativ klein gericht gesagt das was war
denn dann trotzdem das besondere beim
600 polizisten im einsatz weil am rand
dieses zuges eine sehr große zahl ich
würde sagen ungefähr gleich viele also
etwa auch 1000 gegendemonstranten gegen
diese corona gegner waren also ein
linkes spektrum teilweise auch zumindest
optisch dem schwarzen block zu zuordnung
also autonome linke die teilweise auch
in der vergangenheit gewaltbereit waren
die heute sehr zornig waren sehr wütend
auch waren impulsiv waren mit kochtöpfen
und löffeln am rand geklappert haben
krach gemacht haben und diese doch sehr
bürgerliche schweigemarsch menschen da
menge immer wieder belegt haben immer
steht mit nazis und faschisten
ich hatte den eindruck dass sie
tatsächlich sich diesmal den falschen
zug ausgewählt haben wir in protest denn
am mittwoch als die neuen kroner gesetze
hier im bundestag beschlossen worden
sind
da waren tatsächlich zumindest
augenscheinlich und nach ihren symbolen
die sie offen trugen wirklich rechte
menschen und wir haben es ja auch in
anderen demonstrationen in leipzig oder
münchen erlebt dass also rechte kräfte
rechts von der afg auch und eben afd
leute teilweise auf fussball hooligans
sich in diese züge einmischen
wer zu diesen querdenkern dass er also
verschwörungstheoretiker und eben
wirklich auch antisemiten antisemiten
die lautstark da eben ihren hass auf die
straße tragen und diese demonstration
diese an die korona demonstration als
trittbrett benutzen um ihre kruden ideen
auf die straße zu treiben
das war heute meines erachtens zumindest
nicht der fall haben wir so waren die
leute auch sehr überrascht über diesen
heftigen gegendemonstrationen und die
polizei hatte alle hände voll zu tun
diese beiden gruppen zu separieren dass
sie also nicht aufeinander geraten oder
direkt aneinander geraten das ist an
manchen kreuzungen nicht ganz so
gelungen aber standen die sie da
wirklich brüllen gegenüber und haben
sich beschimpft aber letzten endes ist
doch alles friedlich geworden und die
schweige der schweigemarsch hat dann am
alexanderplatz sein ende gefunden und
gegen 14 uhr 45 war dann alles vorbei
vielen dank keine frage dass du das ganz
für uns beobachtet hast